oh by the power of castle hate skull i
am hella far carly and you are somebody
who's looking at me on a video thinking
why is he wearing sunglasses inside
because i felt like it because i think
these are cool and i often forget to
wear them in my real life so i said i'm
going to bring them in we're going to
start out the podcast like that i'm
going to take him off but yes future so
bright so
here we are today on the michael jordan
episode as casey the most handsome
producer on the internet when it comes
to podcasts let's qualify that he said
we're on the michael jordan episode
another line i'm stealing from him but
is it stealing if i give him credit i'd
like to think that i'm just saying hey
dude he's the brains behind this
operation here okay he's coming up with
the jokes he's making analogies for what
episode is what and today we're on the
mj episode episode 23
haters thought we couldn't make it but
here we are almost to six months worth
of podcasts
isn't that incredible whoa right yeah 26
if i'm doing my math right 52 is a whole
year so not bad guys
a lot of people people actually were
saying quite a bit this podcast isn't
going to make it till christmas like the
the initial haters were
you know this will last this many weeks
gonna be like hey hey it's christmas
what uh remember when you said that
take ownership of it radical
responsibility uh we have made it this
far
and some people are even saying it gets
better i don't know i don't have a sense
of these things because i'm watching
myself hyper critically and then at some
point oh maybe it's not that bad i
finish an episode and i go my god i'm
terrible at this but then
maybe i'll listen to it a week later and
be like maybe i'm not so terrible at
this but people in this last episode
seemingly enjoyed it and i do get a lot
of comments like you're getting better
and i don't know if you mean that or not
but it feels good at least and if that's
your honest opinion thank you and i hope
if you're watching and i'm getting worse
at this you can also feel free to tell
me that because i want to know if you're
writing in the comments to tell me how
much i suck but also claiming to not
watch the podcast well
i won okay so
just to start off
this episo it's something that's fresh
on my mind because
it touches on so many interesting things
i met akash singh akash singh
with three a's
a and then k and then double a
from the flagrant 2 podcast he came in
to do fighter in the kid and i wanted to
make sure
uh that i came in and met him and told
him to his face that he's a piece of
[ __ ] just kidding i wanted to tell him
to his face
that i really liked his special um
hopefully i don't get this wrong it's
called bring back a poo are you have you
seen a casey i haven't seen it yet but
i'm aware of it yeah you've heard of it
yeah a lot of chatter online big time
chat big time chatter just
it is a really good special it's like 20
minutes so it's focused it's
uh you know
it's it's focused around this not the
entire thing is about apu but i would
say that
the themes that i took away from it
the message that i got there you go yeah
bring back a poo a comedy special 20
minutes long great editing nice and
tight the dude's really smart and a
great joke writer and i love this
contrarian perspective that he has about
specifically privilege in america
that's a touchy topic for a lot of
people
um and it often gets reduced to a sort
of binary right there's male privilege
there's white male privilege so
obviously i'm on you know the uh the
receiving end of a lot of those
accusations either directly or generally
people saying this and i always feel
uncomfortable pushing back like you know
as a white male like
i don't have that much privilege like
you know
you feel defensive about it if somebody
is criticizing you or or trying to say
that your
accomplishments and where you're at in
life not that i'm like you know some
super successful billionaire
but it's you know you could look at
anything i've ever done and be like well
it's because you're white and because
you're a man and people have told me
that before and i always just feel odd
actually defending myself because it's
like if you're talking with somebody who
believes that what's the likelihood that
they're going to be open-minded to this
right the messenger
in this case isn't great because you
kind of come off as whiny or defensive
however when somebody else
brings this conversation to the table
and somebody who is a quote unquote
person of color i hate that term but
that's a term you know
used by a large portion of the
population describe a non-white person
but akash is an indian who
you know one of the themes that he's
exploring in this is the idea of
being a victim of oppression in america
because
he will also
say
at the front of this special you know of
course i believe in the systemic racism
and black people in america have been
systematically oppressed over the course
of centuries
um
you know that's something i feel like i
haven't heard a lot of great arguments
against and we can take that for granted
but then when you go into okay how does
privilege apply to other things
um you know both in this country and in
the world he's sort of arguing like
we got a pretty good because indians do
actually they're very successful
minority in america um
he's you know he's looking around going
all my you know the people who come from
uh
indian backgrounds or doctors lawyers
entrepreneurs and um
i like that attitude of like there's
nothing to complain about for me right
um
he's uh
and also it opens up another
conversation i think jordan peterson and
again not that i agree with everything
he says but he's a fascinating guy to me
and another guy that i like look you
know at as like oh you have a lot of
hate and i even when i first found out
about jordan peterson i had friends who
were like
you know oh i can't believe you're like
listening to this guy or entertaining
any sort of ideas from a guy who's like
obviously a closet white supremacist or
whatever angle this is of attack i'm
like i don't really see that in like
what he says though because i've
listened to
several hours i'm talking that doesn't
come across to me but anyway one of the
things that he said is like
white privilege exists male privilege
exists but
every different individual
and different categories of people have
different forms of privilege you know
like a pretty girl if you're a super
attractive woman you're telling me you
don't have some of the most potent
privilege in the world um
and the similar argument here you know
that you're privileged compared to
something else an indian is privileged
compared in america compared to somebody
who's uh back in india living in poverty
so
this makes it sound like his whole
special is super serious but he's got
great jokes
and he's got a great point about uh you
know why why apu isn't
racist
he's living the american dream he's
married to a beautiful brown woman he's
got kids he's uh
he owns his own business and sells
overpriced goods
to
unwitting white people i think is the
line so check it out if you hadn't i
guarantee you'll like it and he's a cool
smart dude and i'm glad i talked to him
so
i had another discussion with somebody
that
intersects these two things in my world
acting
and personal training a friend of mine
liam johnson
who actually does apparently listen to
the podcast we'll put that to the test
we're gonna see if he actually listens
to this
and uh
recognizes the fact that i'm talking
about him because i'm using his name so
we had a wide ranging conversation
because he's getting into personal
training a couple things that
uh
you know i had that were takeaways from
this conversation were
the notion of
where your heart is when you want to
work and help people as a trainer
i think if you're getting like there is
a lot of money to be made in fitness but
i love
when you meet people and they're getting
into it for the right reasons because
you became enthusiastic about this and
then you want to share that enthusiasm
with other people and you enjoy helping
people wherever they're at in their
lives and in their fitness journey get a
little bit better
and
i think he was somewhat perhaps
self-conscious about starting training
because he only recently sort of really
got into fitness himself had played
sports growing up but like you know
wasn't so much like a weight room guys
like i
baled hay all summer in oregon 12 hours
a day and that physically prepared me
for
uh you know playing football cool uh
and then
nowadays he's getting into
actually
like learning how to do everything
properly and so we've been in discussion
over the past let's say year he's
updated me on what he's been getting
into but
you know
it's
always interesting to see
like the difference between
people will often brag like oh i've been
working out for 10 years doesn't matter
you could be working out for 10 20 30 40
years and still have no idea what you're
doing because you're ignorant and you're
stuck in your ways and that's why we see
all these people
you know put these videos up of people
who are
in the gym just doing every single
exercise wrong it makes the you know
funny gym fails uh
it's driven by people who are
doing something wrong typically they're
older and typically they're you know so
i'm sure they could have been working
out doing the same exact [ __ ] for
decades but
uh you can learn a lot in six months you
can learn a lot in a year you be can
become proficient in two years and it's
also
you know i got certified as a 23 year
old as a certified strength and
conditioning specialist with the nsca
what i know
now that makes me much more confident as
a trainer is just my ability to get
through to people and understand like
what that person needs because at first
you're like oh i have this information
and i need to come across as a
professional and i need to tell them
this and be authoritative at all times
and you know you have this idea that
like if you don't have all the answers
for everything or if you don't come like
already ready to prescribe somebody the
exact thing that they need
then you're not a good trainer and over
time you realize it's okay to admit when
you don't know what you're talking about
it's okay to admit that hey that's a
question i can't answer and it's okay to
not have all the answers up front until
you collect more information get a sense
of that person both how they can be
motivated and
what the first step is you know from
taking them where they're at now and
assessing their goals and just making
those incremental steps and to me
like so many things it requires
emotional intelligence and understanding
of different personalities and those are
things that
you develop over time you develop those
people skills and empathy and insight
into the human condition that i think
you know it makes it a little bit hard
when you're in your early 20s at least
for me i felt like yeah i knew a lot
about training
but
the ability to work with adults and just
and be confident about like i know this
is what you need that comes and if you
have that already if you have insight
into the human condition you like
helping people you know you're already
on a great path to
uh being a good trainer
and again that as opposed to people who
get in like i could make a lot of money
at this and i'm you know hot or have a
really good body or have some marketing
gimmick and i'm in it to make money
that's still one of the most disgusting
things that i think we see in fitness is
people who it's okay to make money but
who prioritize that who mislead people
who prey on the
insecurities and naivete of
people who are just getting into fitness
to start off their journey i hate that
[ __ ] okay cut it up
all right
i also wanted to say his
girlfriend cat is dealing with some
mysterious
issues with regards to her health like
leg numbness
and
i'll take for granted sometimes that i
can go in like my shoulder injury at
least i know what it is you know at
least i can get imaging and have it uh
an actual answer versus cat has spent
the last few days in the hospital hours
and hours and hours and going back and
forth and you can talk to a neurologist
and a specialist and you know it seems
like they've talked to like many many
people who are trying to do blood work
and scans and this and that and come up
empty-handed and i just can't imagine
how frustrating that would be you know
to just both be feeling like absolute
[ __ ] to the point where i can't even get
to bed because my legs are numb and then
also to not have an answer as to what it
is or when it's going to go away so
another thing to be grateful for is even
just
having answers yes i have injuries yes i
have pain but at least i know what they
are for the most part okay
all right let's take a little break from
all the incredibly interesting things
that i'm telling you in the podcast to
once again talk about kratom my new
favorite thing and i'm being honest here
i started taking it uh last week
before the podcast and i gotta say very
impressed with the results i've
continued to experiment with different
forms of it
this morning i had some of the powder
that happy hippo sells
and i mixed it in like a tea and put
some honey and lemon in there delicious
love the effect took one teaspoon of the
powder
mixed it up
it kind of tastes like matcha actually
but
again very impressed with the results
and i've been reading more and more
about it we're gonna do a deep dive on
kratom very soon i promise but
in the meantime i'm gonna report on my
personal experience
which uh i'll say this it has this
unique combination of
firing up my brain and feeling like i'm
stimulated without viewing on these sort
of anxiety-ridden side effects that you
can have from too much caffeine or other
stimulant consumption
and there's some
science at play there that i just
started reading about but we'll get into
more next week but suffice to say it's
an interesting effect that i enjoy and
specifically when it comes to things
like writing the outline for the podcast
or um coming up with ideas sitting you
know in a chair and relying on my brain
to do work for me which i don't always
do but
to write this uh you know the outline
for the podcast i do
it's it's really incredible and to know
that it's been around for hundreds of
years
and
uh that so many people swear by it for
different reasons but for me personally
i've been able to use it like this i
even use it as a pre-workout feels good
and i'm very picky about pre-workout
stuff because
some feelings i don't really like but i
do enjoy this as both you know a a
nootropic for mental activities but also
something that makes me feel good using
my body in a physical capacity so i urge
you to try it be safe experiment with
low doses on yourself and tell me what
you think i'm really impressed by the
stuff and again the happy hippo brand is
one that you can trust because
it's a wild west out there this is what
cbd used to be and it's hard to regulate
and get the highest quality products but
i can assure you happy hippo has the
best ingredients and that's really
what's important is that getting that
actual quality leaf
which happy hippo has and i could attest
to so visit happyhippo herbals.com and
use promo code thick boy with 3cs for 20
off for life you can keep coming back
and ordering and ordering and ordering
and i genuinely hope this is something
that you try
and does something positive for you let
me know
what
what can we do a liver king meme of the
week let's break up this serious stuff
so we got a picture here this is the
liver king posing with a gun i don't
know guns is that a what do you know
what it is chris chris is coming at you
right now
uh
that looks like a smith wesson i think
okay an m4
you said an m4 yeah i could
okay
yeah i could be wrong it could be an m4
i also feel like i'm going to kiss casey
being this close to him
maybe we get you you're regardless and
he's also got more guns it looks like in
the show this is just like
to me it's like
tough guy with a gun and a camo shirt in
front of a truck right yeah yeah looks
good
but i like the caption of it because i
like how he you know he's portraying his
lifestyle but it's also he's got to get
his message in right and i think he's
really good at this
master market over here there's a simple
reason that so many of us lack purpose
in life we've stripped ourselves of the
most primal purpose known to man that is
guarding the perimeter against danger to
protect one's tribe we've str uh okay
thousands of years ago danger meant
lions hyenas and other tribes to be
certain danger still exists it merely
shows itself in different ways excessive
social media use toxic people
processed foods
the list goes on
so long
as you let it
you don't need a gun to reclaim
ownership over your life your role the
purpose you feel you've lost you just
need some goddamn courage primal so
adopt the nine ancestral tenants lead
from the front and dominate
he is good i don't know if he's writing
these captions but it's like
you got me you know you brought it back
around and that's what i always
i try to do similar things when i post
like have some sort of misleading come
you know it's like have something in
there that's fun to read the caption it
feels like a payoff right and this guy
you know
was like seems to me like he took a cool
picture of the gun and it's like how can
i relate this to my ancestral tenants
yeah well i mean
for years whenever people ask me my
purpose my answer is it's always the
perimeter
i mean so i get what he's saying i get
where he's coming from the perimeter bro
the perimeter yeah
god
i would be the worst guard i would just
be like
falling asleep [ __ ] on my phone just
like what like
or whatever that was you know in ancient
times i'd be distracted by it tablets
looking at your tablets yeah looking at
my actual tablet in stone so i thought
that was a funny little pose because
again it's all it's like this
masculine signaling and also i'm gonna
bring up vladimir putin in a second too
because the word you know you russian
ukraine are going at it but
it just gave me this flash of
you know like
the theatrical masculinity i guess would
be one way to put it you know and i
participate in like by having big
muscles as part of like theatrical
masculinity i get it it's just i'm not
particularly into guns but i would feel
very self-conscious about being like
cool pic of me with a gun
and then also a serious caption
that but hey that's why we love you
liver king
okay uh and we got a meme of the week
from i always try to try to have an
actual post to root this in like no he
is this person and i derive
entertainment just from going to his
page and i hope you do too but also i
love this meme format
where you know it's the guy in the party
up against the wall and we see his
thoughts so he's saying
the liver king's up against the wall
with a big guy with shirtless of course
red chested looking swole and very not
natty and ostensibly
a liver in his hand and he's saying
these people aren't dancing like our
ancestors then the other people in the
party which we usually don't get a
glimpse into
their minds in the typical meme format
they're saying things like what's that
smell
deodorant is a recent invention why is
he so red i don't know but he keeps
asking me for the basic stuff
uh
good meme solid meme love to see people
pimp out those classic formats
now of course i'm going to bless you
with the mark harley meme of the week as
promised last week
daniel rabone bringing it on home
this picture came in so giant
it's my hair on trump i just you know my
hair looks good on a lot of people
like donald trump sort of looks like an
evil magician or something with my hair
doesn't he
um you know some eastern european count
or something i don't know maybe that's
what i look like and it's like no no
mark that's that's what you look like an
evil magician uh
more so than donald trump
stop projecting as they say
you know and that's another important
thing too to me because last week i did
biden this week i did trump i don't want
anybody to think that i'm
not going to give equal air time to
different political viewpoints okay
bipartisanship is important or less so
than bipartisanship is just
giving consideration right because you
can be bipartisan and still you know not
have any desire to seek out the truth
that's one of these logical fallacies
that i i think is very common where
people go like you know
you look at two sides and the truth is
in the middle well not always
right
so
just because politicians are working
together doesn't mean it's good
but
in this case uh you know i have a lot of
friends who are trump supporters a lot
of friends who are
biden supporters or were at some point
and
the one thing that i recognize from
everyone
is that there are good people and dicks
on both sides
um so before you judge anybody for their
political views i think this is a lesson
that i wish i would have learned earlier
in life is
hold something higher than someone's
political beliefs
hold something like
their character who they are how they
treat other peoples
other peoples of the worlds
hold that above somebody's political
views because you'll often find that you
may discredit somebody or dismiss them
because they have differing political
views and turns out they're a totally
great human and you're associating with
somebody else and maybe you connected
over you know your political views but
they're actually a total piece of [ __ ]
so
that's uh you know probably an anomaly
if it actually happens that you find
like i agree with you on everything
politically and then you're actually a
sociopath maybe that person wasn't being
sincere to begin with but i dislike the
idea of seeing past these ideological
differences i think that's the key to
saving humanity
and you know eventually we're gonna have
to accept our political views from china
so you know keep an open mind
uh next 20 years or so all right let me
get a little more carly meme hella shark
harley from henry matassa what is that
some sort of like cartoon shark from is
this a show that it looks like
ninja turtles or something like that but
it looks like a cartoon i've seen before
and it's just a shark with like this
80s rocker hair you're also wearing the
same shirt
oh my god we are wearing the same shirt
he's got a keno clothing
long sleeve pocket tee use code hella 10
at checkout for 10 off you're gonna like
the way you look
so because of we're gonna make this
whole podcast about the liver king i
think is what's really going on remember
i said last week uh this guy mike benoit
was like
uh
you know actually he's daddy because i
know him he responded
and we're keeping it respectful
uh for the most part i know i can veer
towards being a dick when i get
frustrated or think people are naive but
i'm going to try not to do that he
responded to the last video and said
mike benoit here sorry didn't get a
notification of the response man
absolutely i would love to have a chat
with you anytime so it might happen i
might actually talk to mike and get
it's like a
behind the liver
yeah i knew i knew liver king growing up
uh you're right i have not randomly pee
tested the man because last week i said
the only real way to get an idea or
narrow down the possibility of him being
natural is have you randomly drug tested
the guy over the course of years right
of course not that's unfeasible that's
why i said it it's a rhetorical trap to
be like oh you must have this
impossible information or access to this
uh impossible uh set of information
that uh obviously you don't so that's my
way of conversationally tkoing people as
crystalia says
you're right i've not randomly p-tested
the man but i have been to his home in
willis several times delivered several
units to his home and interacted with
his family and staff
i first met brian johnson around 2017 i
would say when he came into our showroom
in conroe texas my former employer
you're absolutely right he could be
lying to my face but i trust the man at
his word i've had meals with my family
and his at his home and we've had
several dealings involved involving tens
of thousands of dollars and the man has
never ever faltered in his word and
that's actually really cool to hear like
you know because
sure i'm making fun of this guy but he
is a person and i i like to hear that at
least with regards to his ethics on
business dealings which i do think is
very important you know and says a lot
about you as a person
um
that he sticks to his word and
apparently he's a really great guy and
that's that's impressive in this day and
age he even has cell phone and internet
signal blockers in his house because he
thinks it interferes with your cellular
system somehow
definitely cuckoo bananas there but i
don't he says that definitely cucumber
so actually
this guy's talking more [ __ ] about liver
king than i am right now but i'm not
gonna go as far as say i don't
you know does it i don't know because
i'm not a scientist i've never looked
into it i come from a linea like i don't
think it causes cancer obviously but you
know
there could be other smaller
disadvantages to having a cell phone on
you all the time i come from a lineage
of aluminum siding salesmen
i love that sentence a lineage of
aluminum sliding uh
lineage of aluminium siding salesman and
i've been in the sales game for almost
20 years now i like to say i developed
an art for spotting a con man or
[ __ ] artist pretty well
and you probably do that's another thing
right with sales like training there's
so much interpersonal intelligence that
this is dependent on
that i have no doubt you have very
advanced social skills and a very
advanced ability to read other people
either way either he's got me hook line
and sinker either where we truly are
looking at a one-of-a-kind one-off
weirdo couple things to say here
first of all okay let me get your
reaction to that
when you when you hear all that did you
like i i just think it's there's two two
separate things you can be an ethical
business person and still take steroids
great point yeah great point and that's
what i was gonna touch on too is
um it's an interesting conflation and
while that makes me like the liver king
more like it makes me go oh he's a cool
guy like i'm you know it affirms what
you kind of suspect like he doesn't look
like a bad guy but that's also
one thing that we've
coupled in modern society and something
that i've had to mentally detach from
and try to convince others and i hope
that we get to a point where we move
away from this idea that
steroids make you a bad person
right because that's essentially what
he's he's defending the accusation that
you know if you're taking steroids and
not being totally forthright about it
then that in and of itself makes you a
bad person now i do have some ethical
issues with that if he's on steroids
obviously and selling you this product
that's predicated on his uh fantastic
physique
and lying it's not ideal but at the same
time
there are so many disincentives for
people these days to talk about their
steroid use right the most obvious ones
being like the rock like what it doesn't
benefit him in any single way it only
would be taking jobs away from him and
other people you know so a guy like him
or john cena or whatever it just
at
this
time in history
it's you can't freely talk about it with
no consequences i feel like personally
he could
and therefore
i do judge him in that sense because he
could be open about a cycle back and in
conjunction with this it makes you know
the
detrimental health effects of steroids
less so because you're going to be so
healthy you know there are things
obviously you can take to mitigate the
side effects of steroids
uh
as far as
you know harming your organs so maybe
eating organ meat would be one of those
things i'd like to you know it'd be cool
because you could prove it be like oh
before i started eating meat and i was
on steroids my blood work and health
looked like this and then it improved
taking the same [ __ ] but again
conflating the two things that you know
steroids make you a bad person or that
uh because i've seen him in person he
seems like a good guy he sticks to his
word and business dealings that means
that he's honest in 100 of the time you
know i try to be honest in in my life
but at the same time omitting like i
don't feel like i owe anybody absolute
transparent honesty at all times it's
ridiculous um so
you know he could just consider that
something that nobody needs to know
that's his own private business but it's
an interesting little
insight because people will say the same
thing about like michael hearn or
different guys who are sort of like
famously like
deniers of steroid use
and the guys will come on back mike's a
good guy it's like i don't give a [ __ ]
you know um that's not the question and
it is just very difficult at the end of
the day to prove
whether or not
somebody is so we speculate but it's
like can i prove it of course not but
you can't prove he's natural and
access to that information would be
impossible to get and the information
doesn't exist unless he's been testing
himself
for years or keeping some log um so
again it's always speculation but just
keep that in mind when you think
somebody is on steroids like well you
don't know um
and don't use it to be a hater speaking
of which
hater of the week first of all we had
some runners up there there must have
been like
this is the same thing that i touched on
last week with the with the whiskey in
the bush
like guys are coming to my page by
the dozens if not hundreds to leave like
lion and bush emojis like which you know
like i get it as a form of
harassment you know like putting a snake
emoji on taylor swift whatever that was
you know like using
bombarding people with emojis as sort of
a standard internet thing it's not like
it offends me it's just like
oh there's a lot of you aren't there but
i do this funny thing where i'll
i won't block the person who leaves a
comment but then i'll see who likes that
comment and then block like
50 people from that just in part because
they don't know they're like why did he
block me
like it's like so petty you know that
it's unexpected but then i won't like
block the person actually leaving that
and this one guy
i forget his nat could look it up right
now but he's like he's done it like four
days in a row where he just leaves the
same and it's like like saying mark
whiskey but spelling it with a g you
know uh mark whiskey
and i don't block guys like that because
part of me is just like
how long do you want to keep this up are
you gonna come to my page every day and
you don't follow me so you have to type
in my name
manually to come to my page and say
uh you know type out emojis
to harass me right um so that's but like
literally hundreds i'm like oh you know
like the cult thing i said last week
it's like oh you can't you can't think
of your own joke can you
and again i'd give you credit if these
things were clever but it always just
it's funny and sort of refreshing
because you're like oh that's that's the
ceiling like you all got to use the hive
mind to come up with
emojis
great tactic
and then this guy just saw this is the
actual hater of the week
brad camilo
comments lol this is under my last
episode ella well dude looks like a pile
of poop from the 70s so gross barfing
emoji
thick between the ears too
what i like about that is it's like just
basically a doo doo joke it's like you
look like doo doo
the fact that it's from the 70s i'm like
actually that is kind of accurate
because if it's like if the poop turns
white and part of it's brown like that
could look like my hair i guess but i
don't want to
assume that he's
inferring that and give him too much
credit because he does sound like
a low iq individual
the thick between the ears comment too i
love because guys will come on and just
be like you're stupid or like your
podcast sucks
and i'm like you know you could write
whatever you want like you could you
could criticize something specifically
and i'd have to respond to it but when
someone's like you're an idiot you're
thick
with three c's
wait right so you're saying back to if
we could circle back to the poo
uh to the what to the poop
from the 70s if you're saying
it's the poop from the 70s but today
i guess so right because it's like what
is this vintage poop like back then it
was like the look of
yeah the pupa like is it that time
at the current that's yeah that's a good
question that's a good uh rhetorical
question there
i think he means
some [ __ ] that was
dropped initially it was fresh in the
1970s so it's now we are talking now so
we're talking about
poop that has
fossilized i guess or or whatever the
appropriate word would be so it was you
know i haven't heard that before with
that qualify like poop from the 70s it
sounds like you just randomly threw it
on it's like you look like [ __ ]
from another decade
but you know keep comments like this
coming if i get a bunch of positive
comments and comments like you suck it
you poop it's like well
if you need a better demonstration of
the intellectual capacity of my haters
i'm not sure one exists we have mr
poopypants here
okay do i have anything else for that oh
nope nope nope but i also just you know
when i do get a bunch of mass haters
like that i get to click on like other
like profiles like i'm not saying i have
uh you know everyone's a basement
dwelling loser but you know you can have
a job you can have different things
going on but what you don't see is a lot
of like ivy league graduates you know or
like
male models
or people who live in major cities and
seem to have like a you know a c-suite
job or something like that
or even a big following so it's always
like zero to a few hundred followers
private profile uh guys often in their
early twenties i've found because i
think it's something you sort of grow up
out of you know um
but you'll see people like one guy's
like harassing me and it's like uh lives
in rural georgia
balding white dude in his 20s and his
wife is 300 pounds okay cool um
got it not saying that's everybody but
you see some patterns emerge
and the patterns aren't impressive
you know what i want to get into a hella
sick fitness page squat university this
is going to be
uh something i probably come back to
this is i'm just going to do a brief one
i've talked to this guy in a podcast
before somebody else invited me on to
have to talk to this guy in zoom he is
so knowledgeable
um
about squatting but so many things right
and he's just like this wellspring of
information rarely do i
go to a page and feel like every single
post
i learn something new um about
you know the mechanics of squatting and
uh you know power lifting or olympic
lifting
the muscles involved how to fix injuries
uh how to
uh even mindset stuff like your approach
to you know like the philosophical
conundrums of like would you rather be
able to do like 600 with
pounds on a squat with less than ideal
form or 500 with perfect form and that
brings up this debate
you know over like what is perfect form
and that's a deep one
because it it there is so much nuance
and variance from person to person and
active debate about different things in
different um
things that aren't true even you know
like the knees over toe thing right but
people have these persistent ideas about
what is good form and what isn't i feel
like if you just visit this page squat
underscore university
literally every single
post is
something that is informative like
fixing the hip shift uh the other day he
posted something about this
weightlifting stunt growth that's a
really interesting question to me and of
course it doesn't but it's a very
persistent myth and so uh you know but
it's not always easy just if somebody
believes that to be like no it's not
true show them something here where they
give examples
uh of
kids weightlifting who grew up to be
full height and there's just no science
obviously on
stunting growth from weightlifting
outside of you if you actually injure
your growth plate sure
you'll get [ __ ] but uh outside of that
nope nope nope okay christian we must
have injured our growth plates
nothing
exactly okay i'm gonna do a hella chef
harley real quick
i've been making this meal a lot i got
some butcher box salmon
and this is one of those things where
like i kind of if i didn't meal prep or
something
i'm putting these
four simple ingredients together this is
salmon from butcher box i take two of
the pieces usually equals about eight
ounces of salmon but i can cook that in
a pan
uh with
these vegetables i got from costco these
are probably my favorite vegetables i've
gotten from costco pura pura pura vida
pura vida fire roasted vegetable melange
what is a melange i don't know but it
sounds fancy
they could have said medley but they
went with melange let's have a vegetable
melange trois a mix of brussels sprouts
mushrooms red onions red and yellow
peppers tossed in extra virgin olive oil
sea salt and cracked black peppercorns
oh so there is a little flavor but yeah
they
like you can microwave them that kind of
tastes like roasted vegetables so it's a
step up right then your standard
corn and peas and
diced carrots frozen vegetables this is
luxury [ __ ] and i want you to try out so
i put
two cups worth of those veggies in the
pan and cover it as the salmon's cooking
i put in a bb go rice cup into the
microwave takes 90 seconds to make this
salmon probably takes like
five to ten minutes to cook and you can
cook it straight from being frozen right
out of the freezer
and
i add the secret ingredient which is
something i picked up a few weeks ago at
costco
kogi korean barbecue sauce kogi is a
place it's a food truck in la that makes
these
korean barbecue burritos of which i've
once ate six in one sitting
don't ever doubt me
i did it on a dare and it was delicious
and
this meal with the rice is gonna be
about 800 calories 62 grams of protein
um
around 80 grams of carbs so usually i
like to keep that you know a little bit
lower than the protein but
this is something if i haven't eaten you
know a lot of carbs in the day this will
be a nice big high protein filling meal
with the vegetables it's great
and the barbecue sauce really ties the
room together
there we go you got it instantly it ties
the room together
okay so
i also wanted to do a bro science
academy today
and talk about maxing out
because this is something that comes up
you know for me for others isaiah was
just talking about how he maxed out on a
deadlift the other day and he hurt his
back and you know i've as i've gotten
heavier and heavier and tried to go for
max lifts like i'm not saying that
they'll happen directly as a result of
that max lift but sometimes
you know the pain that i'm in now and
it's beyond just my shoulder i have like
lower back and hip issues that have
flared up over the past year as i've
gotten heavier and heavier in the
deadlift and
it all leads me to give this general
recommendation that maxing out is not
necessary young men seem to be obsessed
with it and even older men
my client paul
um
suggested maxing out the other day i
think or going up to a weight where i'm
like
if you want to do that we you kind of
have there's a separate approach to
doing it where you want to do it because
sometimes people like oh i hit a set of
five on this weight and like went to
failure i'm feeling really strong you
know like oh i could only do three and i
like let's max out it's like no you
wasted that opportunity
you're no longer fresh you know you just
went to failure on a heavy set of five
you're diminished and compromised so
that's one thing to get rid of is this
idea of like i feel strong let's go for
a max in the middle of a workout
you know
probably not going to work out in your
favor
secondly is there a purpose to it are
you a power lifter are you an olympic
lifter is there some element
uh of competition that you're engaging
in
wherein a single rep backs of any sort
of lift will
uh
you know be part of the competition and
worth therefore practicing if not why
not go for a heavy triple or something
and calculate your one rep max from that
because you can pretty accurately do
that and just keep going up in that
three rep max but for most sports it's
unnecessary and most of the time
it's just your ego going i want to hit
three plates you know i want to squat
five plates or whatever it is um
and i think in general we just
maxing out is a skill in and of itself
to be able to safely recruit the maximum
amount of force on a given compound lift
without injuring yourself
is a skill in and of itself knowing how
to warm up properly knowing how to gauge
the amount of weight based on how the
previous single that you did felt it can
take
years and years of
learning to actually do that so i just
wouldn't do it willy nil nilly i don't
think there's any reason to do that you
can beat yourself and improve and
measure your improvement in so many
other ways
so
and i get it like you know guys are
competitive women are competing whatever
but i just know certain person other
times like i want to know i want to max
out i want to you know somebody did this
and i'm going to
beat them
you don't need to
and there might be some serious
consequences we're going to go back to a
this is why we can't have nice gyms is
this a serious episode i think it is
so
this is the first this is why we can't
have nice gyms where i'm actually upset
at watching this video upset disgusted
i'll go into why warning graphic content
woman
crushed to death while trying to squat
400 pounds inside gym in mexico if you
don't like the way that sounds i
wouldn't watch there's nothing too
gruesome about it but you can see
clearly in the security cam footage she
goes under a bar that's on a smith
machine loaded with four plates there's
some guy who maybe was actually using it
a large guy on the side nobody's
spotting her there's people standing
around her
she
goes to unrack it and squat it and feels
that
obviously that's way too much weight for
her like it looked like somebody like
dared her she's like oh i want to try to
see how that feels
there's a bench underneath her that in
theory would have been for like a bench
or box squat type of movement so that
her butt would be able to sit there and
you'd think that would make it more safe
turns out if you get under that weight
and you feel how heavy he is and she
made a calculation to
try to exit the smith machine quickly by
like backing out of it
but the weight fell so quickly that it
caught her neck on the actual bench and
seemingly broke her neck
um
i saw that and i was just like that is
so [ __ ] stupid like
nobody was spotting her nobody was
warning her like dude this is way too
much way for you to handle uh you know
there's no way that you can do one rep
of 405. even on a smith machine
you know it's just stupid to even
attempt it this is not you know a fun
little cute game to be like
how weak am i let me see and let me put
all the weights on here and it's an
extension of something that i always see
in the gym i've told many stories about
how people like use weights that are
inappropriate for them like can you help
me put the 120s on my shoulder and
you're you know you're six one and weigh
130 pounds and are doing some like weird
quarter squat movement well even with
these heavy dumbbells you can drop those
on your foot you know you can
they can cause you to fall over and hit
something else if you can't control a
weight you shouldn't be using it or you
should take such extreme precautions
like i used to do block outs and bench
press i'd do it in a power cage you know
a weight that i couldn't do for a full
rep but there were safety precautions in
place to make sure that uh you know it
would be impossible for me to harm
myself you also have to learn how to
bail weights you know if you're failing
on a squat i don't need a rack there
because i know how to throw it off my
back it's a kind of counter-intuitive
maybe um because when something's
you you know you usually fail because
the weights coming forward too much and
so you have to like
counteract that instinct by throwing it
backwards but
there are so many things wrong in this
video it pisses me off because it's it's
an extension of all these things we see
all the time and make fun of people
using too much weight on the leg press
you know what if your leg slipped off
and and the weight crushes you you're on
a bench press you see a lot of people
like dropping the bar out of their hands
and if that's a weight that's too much
for you and there's clips on you know it
could easily crush you um in the neck
you know or damage your chest there's
just
so much potential for injury in the gym
when you're using weights that you can't
handle
and that's kind of at the heart of all
this stuff that i you know we post about
these gym fails is like
people doing [ __ ] with with weights they
can't handle in this case somebody
actually died
and i also feel bad like mocking this
person because i remember when my dad
died
they put a picture of him he was
overweight but he got back into like
swimming shape it's just like when
you're 50 or 60 and you have you know
this sort of like
fat in your midsection that like i don't
know it calcifies or whatever it's a
sign of diabetes
you don't look great but he was able to
swim like several miles he died doing an
open water swim for charity and i
remember they posted his obituary
in the newspaper like an article about
his death in this in the swim
and people were like commenting
negatively like in the comment section
to the effect of well he looked like he
was about to die anyway or he looked
like he was obese and like and it was
like so appalling to me i'm like this
[ __ ] person just died and here you
are mocking them of course it's my dad
and that's why you take personal offense
to it when i don't think they mean it
personally but
it just reminded me of like
i feel bad for that person's family
because they're probably dealing with
like
people making fun of her
and
you know going up this idiot and there
were several idiots present but
you know i i feel terrible for the
family and i hope it's a lesson to all
of you
don't use weights you can't handle or
i'm gonna come man handle you
all right what else we got
how smart books are whatevs i want to
start bringing in books okay guys my
little book club here
this one i thought of because
of what's going on with russian ukraine
okay
context i'll always bring up context and
understanding to understand what's going
on right now at the moment obviously
russia is trying to annex certain uh
territories of ukraine and to consider
them you know autonomous
regions that can then align with russia
and basically become russian territories
is my loose understanding right but i
always think about how to analyze
something that's happening as a current
event in the news you always need more
context like who is putin what is russia
one of the books that even as a politics
major
you know who took classes that involved
looking at russia and um you know what
the soviet economy and and
post-soviet economy looked like
things didn't quite click until i read
this book called red notice i'll read it
out the description out
real quick and then go into my takeaways
from it this is a story about an
accidental activist bill browder started
out his adult life as the wall street
maverick whose instincts led him to
russia just after the breakup of the
soviet union where he made his fortune
along the way he exposed corruption and
when he did he barely escaped with his
life his russian lawyer sergey magnitsky
wasn't so lucky he ended up in jail
where he was tortured to death that
changed browder forever he saw the
murderous heart of the putin regime and
has spent the last half decade on a
campaign to expose it because of that he
became putin's number one enemy
especially after browder succeeded in
having a law passed in the united states
the magnitsky act that punishes a list
of russians implicated in the lawyer's
murder putin famously retaliated with a
law that bans americans from adopting
russian orphans a financial caper a
crime thriller and a political crusade
red notice is the story of one man
taking on
uh overpowering odds to change the world
and also the story of how without
intending to he found meaning in his
life okay
yes
does that book appeal to you i don't
know if it does or not but it's a
fantastic read as sort of a thriller in
and of itself but also gives you this
insight into both
uh the post-soviet economy and how these
handful of people became billionaires
because basically like everybody got a
slice of the russian economy after the
collapse of communism right
you get this piece of paper that was
worth like in real terms like a potato
or something like if you were to sell it
on the street but it was a legitimate
share uh you know be like handing you
know a homeless person a stock it's like
what do you want me to do with this
so if you could
buy those from people like you know but
if okay if i gave a homeless person a
meal and then they'll give me their
share the russian economy if you can do
that enough you can buy 20 000 or 30 000
or a million shares of the russian
economy all of a sudden you have
ownership in something that's
uh currently underpriced by you know on
the order of hundred or or a thousand uh
you know percent
and
by figuring this out when there wasn't
the internet and there wasn't these
tools to sort of easily translate things
you know from russian into english
everybody thought he was crazy but he
went over to russia and like
aggregated all these shares of the
russian economy with this understanding
of what was actually going on as they as
they moved to capitalism and the guys
who became these you know handful of
oligarchs in russia basically just did
that really well if you had money and
you were able to seize the opportunity
and buy like you know 30 of the russian
economy um
at you know tremendous markdown well
then guess what the moment the economy
starts to grow you're a billionaire um
so he gets in like that but then
as uh
he becomes more successful he becomes a
target of the putin regime and there's
this interesting saying that that he
repeats like
you know i'm going to butcher the actual
language or translation but there's a
you know an idiom a saying in
russian that's uh you know
this guy like finds a genie you know
rubs him out of the bottle and the guy
the genie's like i'll give you one wish
but whatever i grant you
your neighbor is going to get
twice
right so like if if you ask for a
ferrari he's gonna get two ferraris for
example
the guy thinks about it and goes hmm
whatever i want my neighbor will get
twice
poke out one of my eyes
so that his neighbor can have both eyes
poked out because apparently in russia
there's sort of an ethos of like i'm
cool as long as we're doing all the same
and maybe that's a a holdover from you
know the communist era mentality but i
don't want to see anybody doing better
than me and certainly not a person from
another country so by
accruing all this financial success
um with his investments in
uh you know russian the russian economy
and the oil and gas industries etcetera
he pissed some some people off and so
they started to
[ __ ] with him like deflate his shares in
companies
you know i don't i forget what it was
like but it's obviously like illegal and
totally unfair and just like absolutely
like if you you know it couldn't happen
in america it's like somebody rewriting
the laws about you know what ownership
means in a state-owned organization in
order to
uh take money away from you
but
what what i saw from this book was putin
can do anything he wants and
you will justify it bureaucratically
kind of like they're doing right now um
like the chief the spy chief or
something had some slip up at a press
conference where he he said part of the
plan out loud where he's like and we
accept this notion this motion to become
part of the russian federation and
putin's like
that's next week you know right now
we're just working on autonomy um
and
you know in order to
consolidate power what putin did was he
broke one of these oligarch billionaires
uh
by doing like a show trump made up some
charges show trial and all of a sudden
you know he's in a cage in front of the
whole country uh you know on trial for a
crime he didn't commit and he went from
an oligarch billionaire who crossed
putin in you know perhaps a trivial way
to being thrown in jail for the rest of
his life and then putin looks to the
other guys and goes like does anybody
else want to play ball
anybody else want to try to challenge me
um because i'll do the exact same thing
to you so we see that here and i guess
if he
if he gives an order right it's going to
go down the bureaucratic chain and
everybody can get a justified make it
look like a legitimate trial and you
know file all the right paperwork and
that's a relic of the soviet era is
we're doing everything right it's just
there's no concept of actual individual
liberty or
rule of law just the appearance of that
sometimes right because of the
bureaucratic instruments they have so
like all the paperwork's going to be
fouled it's just like you know
completely false charges so
seeing that and understanding like oh
yes
russia is this kleptocracy
there is no rule of law there is no
individual freedom and therefore you
cannot succeed in that country uh
without the most powerful people looking
at you and going hey we want some of
that you know it's run like a mafia
state
and i think that's interesting to think
about in terms of what he's doing with
ukraine
because i think he treats the region
around him
like like a mafia captain you know it's
a nice country you got day
be a shame if i were to annex it right
something like that
okay do i have any more stuff i don't
know dude
it's like
you know i get to the end of the thing
and like everybody's super interested in
this red notice stuff it's just like
whoa mark you're so you majored in
politics that's crazy dude it's amazing
like wow what what's next dude i don't
know you're gonna have to watch and find
out because i don't know what i'm gonna
do week to week i have so many books
that i've read it's just i could
probably do a different book each week
for the next 15 weeks
and still you know not even be done with
the amount of books that i've read over
the course of my life
20 who knows maybe 25 we're gonna do
each one of them starting with red
notice today so it's your homework
assignment to go read that goddamn book
and understand what's going on in the
world for the first time in your life
all right and vladimir putin huh
you want some of this
you want some of this putin i didn't
think so dude yeah who's the alpha male
of the world now huh yeah [ __ ] like
that
you like that i'll see you on the judo
map bro
you